hey guys this is andrew for
trainingsensors.com so in this video i
want to make a quick update on tesla
i know that a lot of you guys have maybe
some of the stock in their portfolio and
you are wondering
how far the stock can go so let's get
into it
[Music]
so the first thing i want to do with
tesla i want to compare tesla to
volkswagen because tesla is actually a
car manufacturer
so let's quickly see you know some
fundamental
uh data on this stock so the market
capitalization of tesla
is 70 billion us dollar as of
uh the 12th of january when you compare
this to volkswagen
it's basically 10 times bigger because
uh volkswagen has
like a market cap a 75 billion us dollar
let's check how many cars they sold in
2019
all right they sold only 500 000
car so i don't have uh 220 data yet
but it's not very far from this maybe
double
when you look at volkswagen they have
sold 10 million
uh cars so you know it's like same a
ratio of
10 times more so you have here some data
that is showing you guys that uh tesla
stock looks like overvalued when you
look at the pe the p is 140
for car manufacturer it's a lot because
volkswagen uh has only 22.
so once again this stock looks
overvalued
but i don't think that actually is the
right way to look at things all right
because we are talking here about a firm
where people
they don't buy actually the fact that
tesla selling cars
they buy the fact that they just give
the money to elon musk
who has become the richest person in the
world
last week tesla has a market cap bigger
than facebook
right the fifth biggest market cap of
the s p 500
and some people say that elon musk has
just been lucky
let's see now what he's doing with all
this money but maybe he's just gonna
burn
cash you know how the same way he did
with spacek at the beginning
but look guys uh elon musk has proven
analysts
wrong since the beginning and you know
when you have luck in the persistent way
uh maybe this is not luck and i don't
believe this is luck
this is the skill this guy knows how to
make things happen the way he wants and
this is the reason why he has so many
people believing in him
and this is the reason why tesla is
going so high so i don't think it's good
to look at all the analyst statements
because they have
no sense right now the only way
you can actually analyze tesla to me is
using technical analysis
so let's do it so this is tesla let's
have a look
on the daily time frame first and we're
going to try to identify
where are the next resistance levels so
very quickly
here i use idiot wave theory and i try
to find five waves
all right because moves up develop in
five ways
i was basically saying in the video i
did uh two months ago
when tesla was around 450 that i was
bullish the reason
behind that was that we broke here a
downward sloping trend line
uh that was connecting the highs of the
false wave and yeah i was seeing more
upside and the question
you have when you know that there's
gonna be probably a fifth wave is
how far it can go to do that we have a
tool
that is uh working quite well for me
quite efficient
that is fib extensions so i'm gonna
apply this method to tesla
so i'm measuring the previous wave that
was in the same direction so it's the
third wave so i measure the
this third wave and i apply it to the
bottom of the fifth wave
and when i do this you know i have
different levels
that are here you know so the first one
was 600 so i was saying in this video
that tesla is going to 600
because this is the most likely one and
we went there we got rejected and then
we blew it we tested it and go higher
so you know after this consolidation
here appeared
i was bullish here and the question uh
we all have is
how far it can go and once we broke the
61.8
uh ratio of fibonacci the next ones
here 670 760 they are not
strong ratios they are quite weak all
right the next
strong one is 1.618 which is
1030. so this is my target for tesla
uh in the short term i think within uh i
don't know one or two months we're
probably gonna reach this level
and then maybe we're gonna have some
kind of a deeper correction
uh we're gonna see then what is
happening uh maybe we're gonna go to the
next one i don't know maybe we're gonna
go to 1470
then we need to do some technical
analysis again but for now
what i see on this technical analysis is
that
600 has been broken retested and we go
higher
so my next level is 1030. if you want to
enter this trade
what you can do you go on a shorter time
frame
and you can try to identify some support
levels
at which you are you can build some long
position
so i just connect the
lows of the last move up all right so
one low here
one low here and i do this trendline
that is here
and i'm just waiting for the price
action to come back to this level but
once again we are doing technical
analysis
one indicator is not enough we need to
have at least
uh two even better when we have three so
here you can see that on the four hours
time frame which is a very good time
frame to do technical analysis
because it's followed by big asset
managers you can see that the 50 period
moving average
is actually playing a support level
uh quite well here it has been tested
and
it has support the price here again and
here again
so what i kind of uh think is that
probably this uh price might go a little
bit lower
maybe to 760 you know 770
uh maybe in a few days and then the 50
period moving average would be here as
well so we're gonna have
two support levels at the same time so
uh i would be a buyer here i can you can
put a stop loss just below
and the target once again is 1030
all right so you can capture a very nice
move up of 30 percent
all right a bit less maybe yeah 30
something like this
so yeah this is what i see so i repeat i
would see that i'm seeing that the fifth
wave is not finished and it is probably
going to reach
1030 level and once again the big
figures like 1000
i usually some psychological levels so
probably a lot of people
are gonna start to take uh you know
profits at this level
so that's it for me i hope you enjoyed
this video and if you did please don't
forget to hit the like
sub and bell button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new
and stay close to show i'll see you guys